team two things unoverrated underrated
one did you see how many views it has in
the first 30 minutes and two drock and i
just filmed a [ __ ] fire episode hey
everybody and welcome to overrated
underrated with your host gary
vaynerchuk
my trusty friend drock is here with the
questions of the day
and i will give it the thumbs up or the
thumbs down
drock let's go
[Music]
jack carla jack harlow is underrated and
i don't know when you're gonna put this
out but i know he has a new album out
and i think i will be proven
correct hard work understanding of the
ear to the street
true talent the ultimate warrior the
ultimate warrior
is overrated i know a lot of people love
him
but i think he's overrated garyvee
garyvee is obnoxiously all-time
underrated there's confusion in the
system don't let the little heat
that i have now confuse you we're just
[ __ ] getting started
the actual character he-man or the
entire masters of the universe
we'll go with the whole universe whole
universe is
underrated he-man himself overrated ram
man
underrated skeletor underrated moss man
underrated stink or underrated
he-man overrated money money is
overrated
i think too many people are blinded by
thinking money is the north star
instead of happiness and i think a lot
of people would make more money if they
focused on processed
long-term patience and happiness and i
think money leads to a lot of
unhappiness i really believe that
i think money is overrated legacy over
currency
it's great right it's real low-fi
hip-hop
beats i love you guys you guys are
coming up with good [ __ ]
underrated and we'll be historically
correct about that uh
disney world disney world orlando
ah properly rated dunkin donuts
coffee underrated better than starbucks
starbucks starbucks is underrated even
though i said dunkin donuts coffee is
better in one man's opinion than
starbucks faces coffee the execution of
starbucks over the last 40 years
is nothing short of remarkable it is
complete culture
to 12 to 18 year old girls in a lot of
the country it
created an entire category of 24 7
premium coffee
starbucks is underrated college is
overrated as a brand
i believe there are more people today
that believe it's a requirement
it's a need you have to go there it's
imperative
it's much harder in life without a
college degree i do not believe that to
be true i think we're in the presbyters
the early days the dawn
of the vulnerability of college i don't
think the college degree
brings as much value as it used to i
think a lot of people go into debt for
something they're supposed to there's a
lot of great variables
in college but if we're playing the net
net game of this show
it is overrated point collecting coin
collecting
is is it even rated
coins are more valuable than the sports
card world
and i've gone through a huge phenomenon
they're just not contemporary
but i'm gonna say they're underrated as
of right now because it's hard to find
somebody under 50 about that life and
that probably means there's some
opportunity cryptocurrency
cryptocurrencies is slightly underrated
there's a lot of buzz bitcoin is off and
running but i think people are still
underestimating the potential impact of
blockchain and cryptocurrency
on the world over the next you know
century
and for that reason it is underrated the
queen's gamut
the queen's gambit is wildly wildly
underrated
a seven part series that completely put
culture on tilt everybody's about that
life all of you are buying chess boards
and it's just complete insanity and for
me what i like about it is it proves why
i p
and content matter that one show has
probably allowed people to stay
in that netflix universe for an extra
couple years and as you keep getting
that alert then netflix is going to
charge you more you don't care because
that queen got you
off it's one show can make you sign up
for a year's worth
of content paying that 20 bucks a month
the mandalorian i've not watched a
single episode of mandalorian
so you have chosen death the fact that
people
that are cynical like star wars fans who
like like the [ __ ] on everything and
this was so hyped and they love it
means it's [ __ ] fire uh 3d printing
3d printing is underrated because it's
been around for a while the promises of
all this crazy stuff have not
materialized over the last decade
but it doesn't mean the technology isn't
remarkable
some execution in the next decade on 3d
printing is going to happen and have
everybody running out to get a 3d
printer to replicate it
i think 3d printing is underrated the
new york jets
the new york jets are underrated
[Laughter]
are you serious soundcloud cloud
is probably slightly overrated i'm about
that soundcloud life
one of the first five apps on my iphone
the day i got my iphone like one of my
first five apps
big fan of the platform i think a lot of
people watch the show believe that
winning on soundcloud
soundcloud rappers is how you get on and
i think tiktok has taken a lot of that
heat i think the concept of soundcloud
rapper is now
internet rapper is social media rapper
is of the moment
app wrapper and i think for that reason
soundcloud is slightly
overrated one dollar new york pizza one
dollar new york pizza is wildly
underrated that is a super efficient way
to
be on your hustle in those early 20s
that three dollars a day pizza life
might allow you to last an extra year or
two
in that humble dark dirt
environment that allows you to finally
break through and make your dream come
true do not underestimate
inexpensive food as a fuel to your dream
call i think golf is slightly overrated
you suck yeah jackass my inner circle's
pissed right now
nate tyler my brother aj with the way
you can bet on it prop betting now it's
exploded in popularity in a lot of
sectors
because it's on that pedestal of bougie
and
like kind of contemporary hot with a lot
of the young players capturing a lot of
attention i i just have a feeling it's
slightly overrated
soccer proper football is slightly
underrated
[Music]
cannabis cannabis is underrated i think
we lived in that one
demonization of cannabis century that i
think will be a blip in cannabis
history roblox the video game i'm gonna
go with overrated i think it's a blip
like in 20 30 years i don't think we're
in
minecraft zelda mario
madden land rolex rolex the watch
overrated stop buying dumb [ __ ]
rosie the wine slightly overrated
stickers are underrated those things are
[ __ ] delicious
especially the ice cream version the
burger
i haven't had a lot of five guys burger
have i even [ __ ] i've had it once or
twice
like a road jets playoff game what did i
think slightly overrated
right this second slightly underrated
because we're on the we're now on the
downside of its white heat
two years ago so i'm gonna go with
slightly slightly underrated
damn daniel butterfingers butterfingers
are underrated delicious
how about the candy bar land oh the
gummies ones not dot candy
which is garbage uh dots i don't like
those they're too
they they're too sticky i think they
need to roll off
your teeth a little bit more too sticky
i'm going with
slightly no no solidly overrated all
right the final one
yo yes yo-yos are underrated
yo-yos are underrated i think they
should be a much bigger thing in culture
i think more people should be rolling
around at their everyday life
just yo-yoing and [ __ ] and i think
yo-yos are underrated big shout out to
ryan pender i remember you playing with
yo-yo's sophomore year of high school
and i was like that makes sense this was
another episode
of overrated underrated please leave in
the comments below
the answer you most agreed with
and the answer you most disagreed with
we'll see you next time
you